chers collègues donc merci déjà à la
commission des lois de nous accueillir
dans ces locaux qui permettent de faire
du distanciel
tout simplement parce que le jour où
nous avons décidé
[Musique]
avec madame la Présidente c'est audition
commune conjointe on connaissait
évidemment pas la situation
du 19 et qui donc à toutes sortes de
contraintes et qui explique que ce soit
à cause des problématiques de transport
pour rentrer dans les régions ou de
collègues qui voulaient manifester ce
qui explique pourquoi nous sommes aussi
peu nombreux en présentiel mais je sais
qu'il y a pas mal de collègues qui sont
là en distanciel donc on additionne
conjointement avec la commission des
affaires sociales monsieur
pierre-louisbrat président du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites accompagnées
de Monsieur Emmanuel Bretin secrétaire
général
moi personnellement je me réjouis de
cette occasion que nous avons de tenir
une réunion commune avec la Commission
des
de cette commission de cette pardon de
ces commissions spéciales de cette
audition spéciale c'est que on parle
beaucoup du corps les uns les autres on
y reviendra dans nos questions et il me
semblait intéressant d'entendre le corps
en direct et dire c'est à dire
par lui-même avec les questions qui lui
seront posées et donc j'allais dire
aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
elles sont pas corrects
d'accord
d'accord on fait passer le message que
nous sommes à l'Assemblée évidemment il
y a pas de problème pour être distanciel
et je comprends même qu'il y ait des
collègues qui soient dans des situations
de manifestation par contre on vous
parlez et vous activez votre vidéo merci
d'avoir des images qui soient à notre
c'est ça le sens de l'observation du
rapporteur donc le plus simple c'est que
vous mettez votre vidéo que lorsque vous
allez poser la question comme ça il y
aura pas de souci de ce type voilà
c'était pas volontaire bien évidemment
je pense de la part des collègues donc
je reviens sur ce que je disais donc
avant c'est interruption donc l'idée
c'est surtout de vous écouter voilà on
va essayer de le faire de manière un peu
à peu serré parce que il y a des
contraintes à droite à gauche enfin
l'idée c'est évidemment d'avoir d'abord
votre avis d'écouter votre parole donc
je vous cède la parole monsieur bras
pour votre propre
bien évidemment je vous souhaite d'abord
je vous passe d'abord la parole
en tant que président de la commission
des agences sociales et après on passera
monsieur bras excusez-moi
très bien encore un petit peu de
patience monsieur le Président oui bien
le bonjour à toutes et tous merci
monsieur le Président de la Commission
finance je salue bien sûr nos
rapporteurs généraux madame Stéphanie
Rice et Monsieur Cazeneuve
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Secrétaire également général mes chers
collègues alors évidemment je salue
celles et ceux qui sont en présentiel
mais il y a également effectivement
celles et ceux qui sont visio conférence
et j'espère que voilà les choses vont
bien se passer en tous les cas pour
celles et ceux qui vont intervenir alors
que ils sont dans certaines
manifestations effectivement je leur
demanderai également de couper leur leur
caméra si ils sont dans une
manifestation alors je veux bien sûr
d'abord remercier le président de la
commission des finances de son
initiative parce qu'effectivement
c'était son initiative et elle rejoint
également le souhait exprimé au sein de
notre commission bien sûr des affaires
sociales de se saisir du de ce thème
donc des retraites et bien sûr
d'entendre le corps je le remercie
également voilà de la souplesse dont il
a fait preuve en permettant que cette
réunion puisse avoir lieu entre deux
examens de textes puisque nous étions
enseignants encore jusqu'à 13h donc nous
avons fait un déjeuner très très bref là
c'est clair pour nous retrouver à 13h à
13h30
je regrette d'ailleurs que notre
calandre rondrier la semaine prochaine
ne nous permettent pas également de
procéder pour la même audition à savoir
le président du Haut Conseil des
finances publiques on aurait pu
effectivement le faire en ensemble vous
le proposiez d'ailleurs monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
malheureusement nos agendas ne nous le
permettent pas
cela dit je me réjouis bien sûr que nous
puissions le faire aujourd'hui et
commencer nos travaux sur les retraites
avant même l'audition du ministre je
rappelle mes chers collègues je vous
rappelle que nous auditionnerons le
ministre Olivier du soft lundi à 16h30
et bien sûr je compte sur votre présence
le Conseil d'orientation des retraites
contenu de sa composition pluraliste de
ces missions telles qu'elles sont
définies par la loi je le rappelle de sa
méthode consistant à élaborer les
éléments d'un diagnostic partagé et de
la place qu'il a acquise dans le débat
public depuis maintenant 20 ans
s'imposer pour introduire nos très
prochaine discussions sur la réforme des
retraites
parlementaire comme citoyen nous avons
tous besoin effectivement de disposer
d'éléments tangibles pour alimenter nos
réflexions et fonder nos choix de
manière éclairée des éléments factuels
et encore une fois partagé de contribué
à des passionnés et à objectiver en tous
les cas les débats en commission puis
dans l'hémicycle en tout cas j'aimais ce
souhait je vous remercie bien sûr
monsieur le Président et le secrétaire
général de vous être rendu disponible
pour nos commissions et je vous passe
dès à présent la parole monsieur le
président
voilà merci madame le Président merci
monsieur le Président
donc je vais essayer de me faire le
porte-voix du corps parce que le corps
ce n'est pas moi je préside cette
institution mais le corps c'est 42
membres dont des parlementaires quatre
députés quatre sénateurs et je salue
monsieur Marc ferrachi qui a rejoint
récemment le corps c'est l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux c'est à dire les
organisations d'employeur et aussi
toutes les organisations de salariés
puissant représentant des professions
libérales et en représentant de de des
familles de
plus en représentant de la FNSEA ce sont
ensuite toutes les administrations qui
sont intéressées par la question des
retraites et donc ça va de la direction
du budget à la direction du Trésor en
passant par la DSS et j'en oublie et
puis ce sont 5 ou 6 personnalités
qualifiées qui nous aident à travailler
donc le corps ne parle pas au sens de
bien évidemment vous vous doutez lorsque
j'ai évoqué sa composition que toutes
ces organisations n'ont pas la même
vision et la même orientation sur ce
qu'il faut faire en matière de retraite
ce à quoi nous parvenons jusqu'à présent
c'est à faire des éléments de bilan à
travers un rapport annuel qui est
d'ailleurs prescrit par la loi et ce
rapport annuel j'insiste sur le fait que
avant d'être publié il fait consensus
c'est à dire que je ne le public après
avoir demandé l'ensemble des membres
s'il y avait opposition à ce que je le
publie en tant que rapport du corps donc
quand je vais faire référence
directement au rapport a priori c'est
des éléments qui font qu'au seins et
bien évidemment ce consensus n'est
possible que parce que nous travaillons
sur des données sur des constats si nous
tentions au sein du corps de faire des
convergences sur des propositions vous
vous doutez que j'aurai quelques mal à y
parvenir voilà j'ai sûrement pas le
talent pour arriver à
pacifier cette question alors je
voudrais en débutant
ayant un chat pardon excusez-moi je me
demandais ce qui provoquait cette
hilarité dans mes propos l'échappe à
plus que les banderoles j'ai un grand
talent comique mais je pensais pas à ce
point-là
je voulais en débutant parce que c'est
me paraît-il me semble-t-il
l'indicateur le plus synthétique vous
présentez le poids des dépenses de
retraite dans le PIB les retraites c'est
quoi on prélève sur la richesse produite
par les actifs pour permettre le
financement des retraites de ceux qui ne
travaillent plus d'accord et donc là
vous avez la représentation de combien
les retraites pèsent dans le pays en
gros combien il faudrait prélever pour
que le système soit à l'équilibre alors
je ne commande pas le passé le premier
point que vous pouvez voir c'est 2021
avant les projections et donc en 2021
les retraites ça représentait 13,8% du
Pipe c'est-à-dire que sur la route la
richesse produite par les actifs dans
l'année il vient il fallait prélever
très vite si on voulait que le système
soit l'équilibre et j'y reviendrai il
était justement à l'équilibre
ensuite vous avez des courbes et ça
c'est des projections ces projections il
y a des hypothèses je reviendrai dessus
sachez que pour ce qui est en gros
jusqu'en 2030 on est basé sur les
hypothèses économiques du gouvernement
on ne s'écarte pas de ces hypothèses là
après 2030 il n'y a pas d'hypothèse
économique du gouvernement donc nous
sommes obligés de choisir des
hypothèses de base nous avons besoin de
deux hypothèses économiques
fondamentales le taux de chômage et la
croissance de la productivité du travail
sachant que dans notre modèle qui est
modèle très très simple et bien les
salaires augmentent comme la
productivité horaire du travail pour le
chômage traditionnellement nous prenions
7%. nous avions une variante à quatre et
demi que nous n'utilisions quasiment
plus parce que quand nous évoquions de
cette variante à 4 et demi nous
croulions qui ont les sarcasmes de tous
les journalistes regardez ces optimistes
du corps qui pensent que demain le sera
quatre et demi cette année il y a eu un
bouleversement majeur puisque
à l'horizon des prévisions du
gouvernement c'est-à-dire en 2027 le
gouvernement prévoyait un retour un taux
de chômage à 5%. et donc notre 4 et demi
paraissait moins et d'ailleurs quand on
faisait l'exercice avec 7%, ça faisait
que d'un coup il y avait une dépression
très forte après le moment où on sortait
des hypothèses du gouvernement donc là
nous avons refait les calculs nous avons
publié sur notre site avec une hypothèse
de chômage à quatre et demi qui est le
prolongement du 5 auquel le gouvernement
envisage d'aboutir en 2027 donc on est
sur ces bases là ensuite il y a quatre
hypothèses sur la productivité horaire
du travail qui correspondent aux quatre
courbes qui vous voyez ce
[Musique]
qui forme un éventail d'accord
l'hypothèse la moins favorable c'est la
productivité horaire du travail augmente
de 0,7% par an l'hypothèse la plus
favorable c'est elle augmente de 1,6%
par an 0,7 % par an ça vous donne la
courbe grenade en haut et 1,6 ça vous
donne
la courbe en verre en bas alors vous
voyez que c'est une hypothèse centrale
puisque les résultats sont extrêmement
différents selon l'hypothèse que l'on
prend ça s'explique principalement par
le fait que les pensions et même les
salaires reportés au compte étant indexé
en principe et selon la loi sur
l'inflation et bien quand il y a une
forte croissance des salaires et bien la
la le poids des retraites dans la
richesse
et moins important que quand il y a une
croissance des salaires moins important
d'accord c'est pour ça que les résultats
sont différents entre les divers les
hypothèses sur ces quatre hypothèses le
corps dit toujours nous n'en
privilégions aucune néanmoins et c'est
logique le gouvernement ne peut pas
présenter un projet de loi en
trimbalance si je peux me permettre
quatre hypothèses et ainsi de suite donc
lui il fait un choix le choix qui a été
fait dans le cadre de cette réforme
c'est de reprendre l'hypothèse
croissance de la productivité du travail
à 1% c'est à dire en gros de se caler
sur la courbe orange d'accord
lors des précédents débats sur la
réforme précédente celle dite du régime
universel le gouvernement avait fait le
choix de prendre l'hypothèse 1,3
c'est-à-dire la courbe verte d'accord
donc
vous voyez donc les résultats sont
extrêmement différents en gros
d'accord donc en gros et en allant très
très vite les dépenses de retraite vous
le voyez sont globalement stabilisés et
même à très long terme elle diminue dans
trois hypothèses sur 4 dans l'hypothèse
la plus défavorable c'est la 07 et bien
elles augmentent sans augmenter de
manière très très importante puisqu'on
parle de 13 et 8 à 14,4 alors je parle
toujours en pourcentage du Bible donc
pour vous donner des idées de référence
le PIB en 2021 c'était 2500 milliards
donc 1% du PIB c'est 25 milliards et 01
point de PIB qui est notre unité de base
c'est 2,5 milliards d'accord donc
les dépenses de retraite sont dérape pas
elles sont relativement maîtrisées la
plupart des hypothèses elles diminue
plutôt à terme et dans l'hypothèse
retenue par les gouvernements elle
diminue très très peu mais à terme
d'accord en règle générale ce propos
suscite un certain d'étonnement sur la
base la France vieillit on dirait que le
corps ne le sait pas et que parce que
bien évidemment si la France vie les
retraites doivent exploser alors bien
évidemment nous savons que la France
vieillit et effectivement ceci est
retracé sur le graphique de gauche vous
voyez qu'aujourd'hui il y a 1,7
cotisants par retraité et quand 2070 il
n'y en aura plus que 1,2 et ça bien
évidemment c'est l'effet du
vieillissement de la population il y
aura moins de personnes en âge de
travailler relativement aux personnes
qui ont vocation à être à l'âge de la
retraite et
ignorer que cette que ce phénomène là
bien évidemment les dépenses de retraite
déraperaient par rapport aux pub et
exploseraient mais vous voyez qu'il y a
un autre graphique qui est le montant
des pensions des retraités rapportés au
montant des rémunérations des actifs
d'accord et vous voyez que dans ce
graphique on a une diminution et cette
diminution elle est liée à ce que
j'évoquais
auparavant c'est à dire l'indexation des
pensions sur les prix par rapport et pas
sur les salaires comme c'était avant les
années 90 et donc
à la fois il y aura moins de cotisants
par rapport au retraité mais ce qu'on
donnera à chacun des retraités par
rapport à ce que gagne chacun des
cotisants sera moindre donc on est
devant un problème de physique
élémentaire il y a de force d'accord et
la résultante de ces deux forces il se
trouve que c'est le graphique que je
vous ai montré avant d'accord c'est à
dire en gros une stabilisation dans la
plupart des hypothèses des dépenses de
retraite par rapport aux piles d'accord
donc ce qui permet au corps d'affirmer
que les dépenses de retraite ne dérapent
pas sauf aussi voilà en tout cas dans le
cadre des hypothèses convenu et malgré
le vieillissement de la population et
bien évidemment
quand je dis ça il y a bien évidemment
un revers au fait qu'elle ne dérape pas
c'est le fait que le montant des
pensions par rapport aux rémunérations
diminue et que aujourd'hui grâce à ce
montant des pensions les retraités en
niveau de vie
légèrement supérieur à celui de
l'ensemble de la population et que du
fait de l'évolution que je viens
d'évoquer demain
le niveau de vie relatif des retraités
sera inférieur à ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui attention j'ai bien dit le
niveau de vie relative des retraités
c'est-à-dire que par rapport aux actifs
demain ils auront moins mais par rapport
au retraités d'aujourd'hui les retraités
de demain auront un niveau des niveaux
de pension et des niveaux de vie
supérieurs d'accord
n'enlevez pas le mot relatif parce que
certains journalistes parfois enlèvent
le mot relatif et passe du niveau de vie
relatif des retraités va diminuer à le
niveau de vie des retraités va
continuer c'est complètement différent
parce que niveau de vie des retraités va
diminuer c'est vraiment angoissant
niveau de vie des relatif des retraités
c'est une question c'est un problème
mais c'est moins angoissant que le
niveau
allez-y continuez je vais maintenant
passer au solde
je vais maintenant passer au solde
s'il vous plaît
et donc là vous avez le le
passé la courbe la plus forte la courbe
noire vous donne le niveau du solde de
l'ensemble du système des retraites
régime de base et régime complémentaire
je dis ça parce que c'est une différence
avec le solde du système de retraite que
vous voyez quand vous examinez les lois
de financement de la sécurité sociale
dans les lois de financement de la
sécurité sociale il n'y a en tout cas
dans les soldes qui vous sont présentés
que les régimes de base or il se trouve
que ce sont les régimes complémentaires
qui sont excédentaires d'accord mais
donc quand on prend régime de base et
régime complémentaire
et comme on regarde l'ensemble donc du
système vous voyez la courbe je ne la
commente pas je vous montre simplement
que en 2021
dernière année connu il y avait un très
léger excédent 900 millions mais comme
je vous ai dit que pour nous l'unité de
base c'était le Jérôme point de PIB on
dit en gros en 2021 on était à
l'équilibre d'accord
j'insiste sur un point vous entendrez
souvent que le corps
dissimulerait 30 milliards de déficits
d'accord alors donc cette thèse
maintenant est reprise par la plupart
des journalistes ainsi de suite je vais
pas l'examiner au fond ça serait un
débat mais je suis prêt bien évidemment
à avoir ce débat avec vous pourquoi
quelle est la thèse de ceux qui disent
qu'il y a 30 milliards cachés je veux
simplement revenir sur le fait que l'on
dit le corps cash
le corps
reprend ici les données pour les régimes
de base qui sont celles fournies par le
gouvernement dans les lois de
financement de la sécurité sociale et
qui sont celles sur la base de lequel
vous discutez d'accord donc je tiens à
dire que le corps ne cache pas 30
milliards ou que si le corps cache 30
milliards c'est le gouvernement avec la
complicité du Parlement tout groupe
politique confondu parce que je n'ai
jamais vu de débat au Parlement sur les
données de base du plfs des débats sur
le pffs mais pas sur les données de base
et donc ce n'est pas le corps qui cache
30 milliards c'est le gouvernement avec
la complicité du Parlement tout ré tout
parti tout groupe politique confondu qui
cache 30 médias voilà donc après bien
évidemment c'est un débat le débat le
débat au fond il peut avoir lieu et
franchement si vous l'avez au Parlement
et si vous changez la manière de
comptabiliser le déficit en LSS il est
clair que les membres du corps notamment
les administrations mais je pense tout
le monde il est parlementaires bien on
changera la manière dont on dans ton
calcul le déficit donc voilà le déficit
pour le passé et en 2021 nous sommes à
l'équilibre ensuite voilà les
projections donc comme vous avez vu que
les dépenses n'avaient pas la même part
dans le PIB selon les hypothèses bien
sûr le solde vous verrez que le solde
n'est pas le même selon les hypothèses
donc en gros ce que vous dit le
graphique en projection c'est que en
2022 on va aussi là on va pouvoir dire
pas qu'on est à l'équilibre mais qu'on
est un excédent mais qu'ensuite le solde
va se creuser et vous voyez que dans une
seule hypothèse on revient à l'équilibre
en 2045 et que dans l'hypothèse
privilégiée pour qui sert de référence
dans le cadre de la réforme c'est à dire
toujours la courbe orange et bien ce
déficit il perdure même jusqu'en 2070
alors là deuxième étonnement les
dépenses ne dérapent pas
on commence à l'équilibre comment le
solde peut-il se creuser à priori parce
que nous comme nous projetons les
ressources nous projetons les ressources
à taux de cotisation constante et donc a
priori comme la base des cotisations
augmente comme le PIB ça devrait
augmenter comme le PIB et donc si les
dépenses ne dérapent pas il ne devraient
pas y avoir de solde c'est là qu'il y a
des évolutions qui ne sont pas du tout
intuitives le solde va se creuser parce
qu'il va y avoir des évolutions
j'allais dire négative sur les
ressources et qui ne tiennent pas au
fait qu'on aurait projeté une baisse de
tel ou tel cotisation et c'est pas du
tout impulsif donc
ces trois phénomènes qui sont assez
particuliers qui vont expliquer cette
baisse des ressources pour les retraites
pourquoi les ressources vont-elles
baisser en pourcentage du PIB alors même
que nous sommes à taux de cotisations
échangées trois phénomènes premièrement
le régime de fonctionnaires de l'État
les ressources qui vont au régime des
fonctionnaires de l'État elles ne sont
pas au fond déterminées par un taux de
cotisation elles sont déterminées par
une convention celle qu'on applique tous
celle qu'on applique tous qui est les
régimes de retraite de l'État il est
toujours à l'équilibre d'accord et c'est
celle que vous utilisez implicitement
quand vous quand vous quand vous
examinez le PLFSS or il se trouve que
les dépenses de retraite de l'État pour
ces fonctionnaires vont diminuer et
comme dans ce régime là les ressources
correspondent aux dépenses et bien comme
les dépenses de ce régime là diminue les
ressources vont elles-mêmes diminuer
premier effet deuxième effet un effet
CNRACL la CNRACL est un régime ou le
taux de cotisation 41% et bien supérieur
au taux de cotisation par exemple dans
le privé
en gros 28% dans le privé or il se
trouve que
la part des rémunérations générales dans
l'ensemble des rémunérations va diminuer
c'est à dire qu'en gros ceux qui paye le
plus vont peser moins dans l'ensemble
des rémunérations alors pourquoi ça va
diminuer dans l'ensemble de rémunération
on pourrait y revenir si vous le voulez
c'est parce qu'on a des hypothèses sur
l'évolution des rémunérations et des
effectifs dans ces régimes là c'est à
dire dans les hôpitaux et dans les
collectivités royales qui sont
particulières et qui sont qui font que
ça va moins évoluer que dans l'ensemble
de l'économie et notamment dans le
secteur privé et donc vous voyez que
comme ceux qui payent le plus devant
demain être pesé moins dans l'ensemble
des ressources par un effet structure ça
va faire baisser la part des ressources
retraite dans le PIB dernier effet mais
beaucoup plus mineur certaines
ressources des retraites viennent de la
branche famille ou du chômage prise en
charge de certaines cotisations et prise
en charge de certaines droits familiaux
comme demain on prévoit un projection
démographique qui aura moins d'enfants
et comment on prévoit qu'il y aura moins
de chômeurs puisque on va passer à 5% et
bien il y aura moins de ressources qui
viennent de ces régimes donc au total
on peut décomposer
le l'évolution du solde entre un effet
dépense et un effet ressources puisqu'on
parle en 2021 d'un équilibre à très vite
donc vous avez là dans les quatre
hypothèses je vais rester sur
l'hypothèse 1% et chômage à 4 et demi
qui est l'hypothèse de référence du
gouvernement pour la réforme et par
exemple ce tableau se lit de la manière
suivante en 2027 le solde du régime des
retraites sera à hauteur de 0,4% du PIB
et il sera hauteur des 0,4% du Pipe
parce qu'on aura eu moins 0 un point de
PIB sur les dépenses et -03% de PIB sur
les ressources
si par exemple on prend pas 2027 mais on
prend 2046 c'est-à-dire un peu après le
solde sera à -07 d'accord mais vous
voyez que là l'effet dépense des
retraites c'est zéro c'est à dire que en
gros en pourcentage du PIB en 2046 les
dépenses de retraite seront au même
niveau qu'elles étaient en 2021 mais que
tout le solde est lié par un effet
ressources et cet effet ressource il est
lui-même lié aux trois phénomènes que
j'ai évoqués précédemment et vous avez
vu que ces phénomènes là sont pas
complètement intuitif d'ailleurs je suis
prêt à revenir si vous avez besoin que
que vous allez le besoin que je revienne
là-dessus donc en gros
des propos le message du corps dont on
dit qu'il est contradictoire
ne l'est pas tant que ça puisque on peut
à la fois dire que les dépenses ne vont
pas déraper on peut à la fois dire qu'il
va y avoir de même des déficits et la
clé de cette contradiction apparente
c'est les déficits vont s'expliquer en
très large partie par un effet
ressources et cet effet ressource comme
vous l'avez vu n'est pas intuitif
d'accord
alors je vous ai dit que les dépenses de
retraite ne dérapaient pas ce que je
voudrais aussi vous signaler c'est que
la révolution en tout cas dans la
période dans la période juste à venir
n'est pas compatible avec les objectifs
de finances publiques actuelles du
gouvernement
elle ne dérape pas mais elles vont
augmenter en réel de 1,8% sur les 5 ans
qui viennent d'accord or
le gouvernement a un objectif sur les
dépenses publiques dans leur globalité
et les dépenses de retraite c'est 25%
des dépenses publiques d'accord donc
quand on a un objectif sur les dépenses
publiques
bien évidemment on ne peut pas ne pas
penser aux retraites parce que ça fait
25% de l'ensemble l'objectif du
gouvernement tel qu'il était exprimé
après la remise du pestable de juillet
2022 c'était on veut réduire le déficit
public à 2,9 en 2027 on veut maîtriser
voire réduire un peu les prélèvements
obligatoires et il s'en déduit un
objectif sur les dépenses et cet
objectif sur les dépenses il se
formulait de la manière suivante les
dépenses publiques globalement ne
doivent pas augmenter en réel de plus de
0,6% par an or vous voyez bien que dès
lors qu'on a 25% des dépenses publiques
qui augmentent de 1,8
il est il est quasiment impossible
d'obtenir 06 sur l'ensemble parce que ça
voudrait dire que sur les 5 les 75% hors
retraite mais 75% en retraite c'est quoi
c'est le soutien à l'économie c'est la
défense c'est l'éducation c'est la
police c'est la justice c'est la santé
c'est lambda mais enfin voilà il serait
très difficile d'obtenir 06 sur
l'essence dès lors que l'on tolère 1,8
sur les retraites donc les dépenses de
retraite ne dérapent pas mais elles ne
sont pas compatibles avec la politique
les objectifs de politique économique et
de finances publiques du gouvernement
alors bien évidemment cette notation
elle est inscrite dans le rapport du
corps mais certainement du corps on dit
mais nous les objectifs de politique
économique du gouvernement nous ne
sommes pas tenus enfin ça ne tombe pas
engagés et donc dans le rapport du corps
on a voulu noter cette
cette contradiction c'est voilà et bien
précisé même si tous les membres du
corps ne se sentent pas engagés par les
objectifs de politique économique du
gouvernement dernier point sur les
dettes et les réserves
nous essayons chaque année dans le
rapport de faire un point sur la
situation patrimoine patrimoniale net
du système de retraite en général et
donc dans ce système de retraite il y a
des réserves et il y a des dettes les
dettes elles sont essentiellement
portées à la cadette puisque la sagesse
a repris les déficits accumulés et puis
les dettes elles sont dans certains
régimes je vais y revenir et puis elles
sont au fond de réserves des retraites
donc vous avez le tableau je vous laisse
le lire mais au total fin 2021 la
situation patrimoniale nette du
système de retraite c'était 163
milliards 6,5% du PIB c'est une partie
du patrimoine net des administrations
publiques parce qu'on parle beaucoup de
la dette des administrations publiques
il y a aussi un patrimoine des
administrations publiques et l'Insee fin
2021 évoluer le patrimoine net des
administrations publiques à 15 % du pile
alors on pourrait se dire bah voilà on a
trouvé la solution il y a 160 milliards
de réserves le problème c'est que ces
réserves elles ne sont pas j'allais dire
à tout le monde ce n'est pas un bien
commun ou un bien collectif ces réserves
elles sont essentiellement dans des
régimes complémentaires qui sont
d'ailleurs les régimes excédentaires
pour l'essentiel vous avez la liste de
tous les régimes dans le rapport du
corps pour l'essentiel c'est des
réserves Arco Agirc c'est quasiment la
moitié des des la moitié des des 180 des
180 milliards
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire sur ce
qu'on peut retirer du rapport du corps
sur la
sur la situation financière je me tourne
vers vous madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Président est-ce que je m'arrête là
sur mes propos est-ce que je vais un peu
plus loin puisque je propose que vous
arrêtiez là parce que vous allez voir
avec les questions vous allez avoir le
casion de de creuser les choses alors
pour vous dire un petit peu comment on
va faire on va commencer par les
questions de moi-même et des rapporteurs
auxquels on vous invitera à répondre et
après on passera aux questions de groupe
auxquelles on vous invitera à répondre
et un certain nombre de questions qui se
sont ajoutés pour ma part j'en ai
plusieurs je vais essayer d'être rapide
la première découle un peu de ce que
vous venez de dire qui me semble
important c'est à dire la confirmation
que les dépenses de retraite ne dérapent
pas
que le déficit augmente et que la clé de
cette augmentation difficile et dans les
ressources alors sur le fait que ça ne
dérape pas j'observe une chose d'après
votre tableau mais ça ça a déjà été
commenté c'est qu'on s'aperçoit que en
gros au moins dans trois des quatre
scénarios
le pourcentage des dépenses de retraite
dans le PIB
redevient stable selon les scénarios
entre on va dire à peu près 2035 et
2047 sauf pour le dernier scénario et
après il baisse bon donc c'est je
suppose qu'il vous fait dire que
elle ne dépense pas alors ma première
question c'est aussi une réflexion c'est
qu'à partir du moment où la clé c'est le
problème des ressources on peut supposer
que on peut aller chercher d'autres
sources dans cette période que les
ressources actuelles
donc nous on l'a pointé en termes
d'exonération en termes en termes de
en termes de
taxation par exemple de revenus adossés
sur d'autres excusez-moi mais c'est
possible parce que sinon on va tous
commenter et y compris pour les gens qui
nous écoutent à l'extérieur ça va pas
être facile donc donc c'est un peu ma
question réflexion c'est à dire si j'ai
bien compris ce que vous dites c'est que
la partie là il y a des choix politiques
qu'est-ce qu'on soit on modifie du coup
j'allais dire les les clés qui
permettent des paraly retraite les
cotisations ce qu'on pourrait aller
chercher d'autres ressources puisque le
pays le pourcentage dans le PIB lui
n'augmente pas donc ça c'est une
première question un peu globale ensuite
j'ai des questions plus précises bon
aujourd'hui chacun peut à s'appuie sur
les scénarios du corps je vais regarder
sur quoi s'appuie le gouvernement donc
vous l'avez dit s'appuie sur le scénario
qui prévoit que déficit sera 0,7% du PIB
en 2050 et comme le PIB aura plus que
doublé d'ici 2050 07% du PIB
correspondront en 2050 à 44 milliards
d'euros ce que nous donne les graphiques
présentés par le gouvernement ce qui
m'étonne un peu c'est que pour comparer
une valeur dans le temps il faut un
référentiel commun et d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça que j'ai noté que le corps
s'exprime toujours en pourcentage de PIB
et non pas en traduction de valeur euro
puisque de fait le montant du PIB va
augmenter
est-ce qu'il est pas trompeur d'après
vous de présenter l'évolution du déficit
de retraite dans le temps en euros
courant comme le fait le gouvernement
dans ses tableaux contre l'usage
scientifique plutôt qu'en pourcentage de
PIB comme le fait le corps ça c'est une
première question la deuxième question
vous l'avez abordé mais je voudrais y
revenir parce que dans le scénario du
gouvernement
il se repose sur la convention dite
équilibre permanent des régimes EPR qui
suppose une diminution progressive de
l'effort de l'État dans le financement
du système de retraite qui est
d'aujourd'hui
qui découle de la baisse du poids de
l'emploi public dans le poids total vous
demandez pourquoi ça doit être le cas et
effectivement vous avez d'autres
conventions que vous présentez qui
expliquent un peu les différences de
scénario avec son appel celui de
l'effort de l'État constance et l'État
maintient son niveau de contribution
actuelle et du coup le système ne serait
plus difficile en 2050 donc pas question
est là est-ce que la convention européen
qui parie sur une baisse de l'effort de
l'État dans le financement du système de
retraite qui découle de la baisse de
l'emploi public dans l'emploi total ils
vont tout le monde même du du
fluctuation du taux d'indice qui serait
qui ne suivraient pas l'inflation est-ce
que finalement tout ça n'apparaît pas
situé politiquement et pourquoi il
serait plus probable qu'une hausse de
cette part et dès lors ne pensez-vous
pas que la convention dite ee C
c'est-à-dire telle à peu près qui est
définie aujourd'hui en termes de de
d'apport de l'État devrait pas être
considéré comme central et troisième
question je souhaitais vous poser c'est
sur le coup social des
réforme proposée
aujourd'hui on a le gouvernement
conserve les âges de départ actuel pour
les personnes avalides en situation
handicap ça diminue de 20% les économies
attendues à cela s'ajoutent des dépenses
sociales engendrées par la réforme une
image sociale à validité ça c'est le
dress qui dit ça environ estimé à 3,5
milliards d'euros 277
000 chômeurs supplémentaires horizon 10
ans si on retient compte non pas des
prévisions à 4,5% du gouvernement ça je
vous l'accorde mais vous observerez que
pour l'instant le la courbe du chômage
ne suit pas vraiment cette évolution
mais celle donc proposée par le FCE ça
fera 2,8 milliards de dépenses
supplémentaires dans le chômage dû à
cette réforme ma question c'est quel
regard portez-vous sur la faiblesse de
l'impact budgétaire de la réforme dans
son ensemble et donc de ces évaluations
de l'OFCE voilà une série de questions
que pour ma part je souhaitais vous
poser et je passe la parole au je crois
que dans l'ordre c'était
de la commission des affaires sociales
après on passera monsieur Cazeneuve
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
président
e je vous remercie de cette présentation
complète et salut l'organisation de
cette audition qui constitue un premier
jalon dans le débat parlementaire que
nous devons avoir sur la réforme des
retraites d'une manière que je souhaite
aussi éloigner que possible des idées
préconçues sur un sujet particulièrement
complexe les rapports rendus chaque
année par votre conseil attestent de
cette complexité le dernier d'entre eux
a été naturellement abondamment commenté
je crois qu'il est important de remplir
rapidement comme vous l'avez fait
quelques éléments qui sont inscrits
s'agissant de l'existence d'un déficit
qui a pu être largement contestée le
rapport de septembre dernier pouvait
pourtant difficilement être plus clair à
l'horizon 2032 quel que soit la
convention retenue ou l'hypothèse
sous-jacente de productivité au travail
le système des retraites est en déficit
à un niveau qui varie entre 0,5 et 1% du
PIB
a droit inchangé dans un scénario
central où notre pays atteindrait le
plein emploi en 2027 se déficit serait
de 14 milliards d'euros en 2032
s'agissant des seules dépenses la
révision des scénarios démographiques
comme économiques vous conduit à estimer
qu'elle serait supérieure de près d'un
pourcents du PIB par rapport à vos
prévisions de juin 2021 à horizon 2032
le comité de suivi des retraites qui est
l'outil de pilotage de notre système de
retraite ne s’y est d'ailleurs pas
trompé dans son avis rendu sur la base
de vos hypothèses en septembre dernier
sans se prononcer sur le contenu d'une
réforme ce Comité souligne je cite que
notre décision se fera dans un contexte
désormais bien moins permissif pour
l'endettement public nous aurons
naturellement dans cette commission des
débats quant aux meilleures manières de
réduire ce déficit je voudrais
m'attarder sur ce que notre majorité
souhaite faire avec la réforme permettre
au plus grand nombre de nos concitoyens
de travailler à commencer par les
seniors aussi ma question sera très
simple quel est l'impact d'un recul de
l'âge de départ à la retraite sur
l'emploi des seniors selon les analyses
du corps merci
merci beaucoup monsieur Cazeneuve
merci monsieur le Président de la
présidente
merci beaucoup pour votre présentation
très très synthétique moi j'aurais cinq
observations si vous permettez qui sont
liés lecture que je fais de votre
document et deux questions la première
c'est
comme vous le soulignez dans le l'état
actuel de la loi et sans réforme
supplémentaire l'âge effectif de départ
à la retraite va atteindre d'ici une
dizaine d'années 64 ans compte tenu
notamment de l'allongement de la durée
de cotisation prévue par la loi de 2014
qui a été adopté à initiative de la
gauche
64 ans c'est d'ailleurs l'âge de départ
qui équilibre le système dans l'un des
scénarios centraux repris par vous à
horizon 2030 vous le dites très
clairement au total notre proposition de
fixer l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite à 65 ans tire en partie les
conséquences de ce qui va être observé
dans les prochaines années
et répond à notre souci d'équilibrer
notre système de répartition deuxième
observation comme vous le relevez dans
votre rapport le niveau de vie des
retraités va en valeur relative
repasser sous le niveau de vie des
actifs d'ici 5 ans à terme sans réforme
il y aurait un recul de l'ordre de 20
points par entre le niveau de vie des
retraités celui des actifs autrement dit
ne rien faire c'est acter un
déclassement de l'ensemble de nos
retraités aussi nous souhaitons lutter
contre cette érosion mécanique du niveau
de vie relative des retraités par
rapport à l'ensemble de la population
avec la fixation du minimum
des pensions à 85% du SMIC et
l'augmentation du montant des pensions
liés au report de l'âge légal de départ
à la retraite troisième remarque par
rapport à votre précédent rapport aux
projections annuelles sont marquées par
une dégradation de vos perspectives pour
notre système de retraite c'est vrai
pour la démographie le rapport entre
actif et retraité va se dégrader plus
vite
qu'attendue on va bientôt être dans un
rapport plus proche de 1 que de 2
le bilan démographique de 2022 que lisse
l'INSEE vient de publier il y a 48
heures nous rappelle douloureusement que
la situation risque encore de se
détériorer s'agissant de la productivité
du travail votre scénario le plus
défavorable et celui d'une évolution de
0,7% annuels or 07% c'est le taux
constaté entre 2010 et 2019 donc
attention faire
le scénario le plus défavorable mais il
est quand même pas loin de la réalité de
ce que nous avons vécu et des scénarios
que vous proposez à 1,6 me paraisse
absolument éloigné de ce que nous
pouvons hélas projeter quatrième
remarque vous affirmez dans votre
synthèse sur les 25 prochaines années le
système de retraite serait en moyenne
déficitaire quel que soit la convention
et le scénario retenu
en partant de vos prévisions fondées sur
la convention dite EPR j'observe qu'en
dessous d'un taux annuel de l'ordre 1,5%
pour la productivité annuelle de votre
travail notre système de retraite n'est
jamais à l'équilibre jusqu'en 2070
c'est pas 25 ans c'est jamais à
l'équilibre en dessous de cette
productivité avec une hypothèse de
chômage de
4,5%, c'est le retour au plein d'emploi
ce que nous souhaitons et pour lequel
nous travaillons évidemment donc sont
difficile annuel atteint même 90
milliards d'euros environ à cette date
dans le pire des cas et environ 40
milliards dans votre scénario central
retenus par le gouvernement au demeurant
le système par répartition qui doit
financer les pensions d'aujourd'hui par
les cotisations qui est-ce d'aujourd'hui
n'est plus en mesure d'assurer le
financement on a tout été du système
déjà un peu le cas évidemment s'agissant
notamment de certains régimes spéciaux
pour lequel l'État compense chaque année
des cinquième et dernière remarque le
projet de réforme dans le gouvernement
va prochainement nous saisir ne prend
personne par surprise même parler du
contenu des campagnes présidentielles et
législatives la réforme est inscrite
comme le corps comme vous venez de le
souligner dans nos perspectives de
finances publiques en particulier dans
le pestable nous sommes donc au
rendez-vous des engagements pris pour
ces raisons il m'apparaît donc impératif
de réformer d'un système de retraite
d'autant plus que comme vous le savez il
nous faut porter une attention
particulière à la maîtrise des dépenses
publiques au risque d'un effondrement
global de notre système puisque ça n'est
jamais le bon moment faisons-le
maintenant dans la clarté et le respect
de nos institutions bien merci deux
questions ah je me demandais si
je fais rapidement monsieur le Président
100% des gains financiers de la réforme
des retraites iront au financement du
système des retraites c'est vrai et il
faut le répéter ceci dit quel regard
portez-vous
sur la pertinence des travaux récents de
la DG trésor
qui a modélisé il y a un nom l'ensemble
des impacts financiers économiques d'un
rapport de deux ans de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite qui se traduisent
notamment par une amélioration
substantielle de l'emploi de l'activité
des finances publiques deuxième question
les parties 4 et 5 de votre dernier
rapport annuel porte sur l'équité entre
les assurés
la solidarité avec les plus modeste les
femmes notamment et sur les changements
de niveau de vie lors du passage à la
retraite sur ces sujets quels
commentaires pouvez-vous faire
s'agissant des impacts de l'impact des
dispositions de justice sociale compris
dans la réforme l'amélioration du
dispositif carrière longue
l'anticipation du départ retraite pour
les Invalides en cas d'inaptitude ou
dans le cadre du Sud médical le
relèvement de la pension minimale et la
validation de trimestres pour les
aidants les femmes ayant bénéficié de
congés parentaux les personnes ayant
accomplies des travaux du thé
collective ou de l'apprentissage je vous
remercie
bien merci monsieur le rapporteur donc
je vous propose de répondre aux
questions qui vous ont été posées par
les trois personnes
on a toute l'après-midi ou non non
je me permets de le dire comme on a pas
toute l'après-midi je trouve normal que
le rapporteur général moi j'ai pas été
hier ma position sur les retraites mais
si après on pouvait surtout poser des
questions ça serait bien parce que sinon
là on va commencer à débat l'assembler
là pour des heures quoi voilà c'est ça
que je veux dire mais qui à travers des
questions quoi Monsieur monsieur le
dans les réponses aux questions donc moi
mon propos c'est de vous éclairer sur le
système de retraite à partir des travaux
du corps ce n'est pas de faire des
propositions ou de choisir des
orientations donc par exemple moi je ne
fais je veux dire je vous ai dit comment
je pense à votre première question
monsieur le Président je vous ai dit
quels étaient les origines du déficit et
j'ai essayé de vous expliquer la part
des dépenses et des ressources je n'en
tire aucune conclusion sur ce qu'il faut
faire après bien évidemment je je ne
suis pas complètement naïf et je pense
que certains peuvent en tirer des conc
mais c'est pas à moi de le faire donc
c'est pas pour voter en touche mais je
vous attendez pas à ce que je vous
réponds sur est-ce que la présentation
du gouvernement est trompeuse là aussi
je n'ai jamais dire que le gouvernement
serait trompeur il est clair que nous
pour des raisons de de clarté on préfère
parler dans ce langage de 0,1 point de
PIB et pourcentage du PIB parce que
effectivement quand on est en nominal
d'une part il y a derrière des des
hypothèses d'inflation sur 10 20 ans
alors déjà là sur les deux ans nous
allons avoir 10% d'inflation mais vous
prenez 20 ans d'inflation 1 euro dans 30
ans ça veut rien dire par rapport à
aujourd'hui et puis les hypothèques
d'inflation peuvent changer dans les
voilà et puis par ailleurs et bien si
vous devez payer demain sans et que vous
gagnez 1000 et bien ça a pas la même ça
pas la même porter que si vous devez
payer 100 et que vous gagnez 5000 or le
PIB va alors ça dépend des hypothèses
mais
augmenter donc c'est pour ça que nous
préférons nous parler en règle générale
en
pourcentage du pays d'ailleurs je note
que dans la plupart des textes le bestab
voilà c'est exprimé en pourcentage du
PIB et qu'à la commission des finances
vous ne parlez que le pourcentage du PIB
et vous évitez parce que vous savez que
voilà voilà sur la Convention européenne
convention
convention EC alors je vous ai présenté
comment surpr parce que c'est la
référence quelque chose et le
gouvernement la convention aussi nous
l'utilisions dans les rapports du corps
à titre pédagogique c'était pour voir
l'effet du du dans les trois dans les
trois éléments
en gros
voilà dans les trois éléments qui
expliquent la diminution des ressources
la convention EC ça consiste en quoi ça
consiste à neutraliser le premier
élément le l'élément fonctionnaire de
l'État donc pour nous cette convention
elle avait un vocation pédagogique pour
montrer que une partie du déficit ou de
l'évolution du solde tenez à cette
évolution particulière d'un régime ou
les dépenses étaient
alignés enfin les ressources étaient
alignées sur les dépenses maintenant vu
que cette convention de s'est suscitée
même au sein du corps des débats et
ainsi de suite donc je préfère aller au
bout de la pédagogie et vous faire la
présentation que je vous ai fait
aujourd'hui en vous disant voilà il y a
des dépenses il y a des ressources voilà
pourquoi il y a une déficit c'est lié
aux ressources il y a trois phénomènes
parce que plutôt que en plus ça me
permet de ne pas en mettre un exergue
mais de choper les trois dans l'analyse
d'accord de prendre en compte les trois
dans l'analyse voilà mais bien
évidemment tant que les membres du corps
n'ont pas décidé de donner la condition
la convention EC vous avez les résultats
dans dans le rapport et sur le site du
corps et puis vous pouvez vous y référer
si vous voulez
je vous avoue que votre troisième
question j'ai un peu de mal non non la
troisième question c'était elle était
précise c'était sur l'impact budgétaire
de la réforme dans son ensemble sur les
questions de dépenses sociales qui sont
souvent pris en compte c'est-à-dire
j'avais noté les dépenses minima sociaux
invalidité d'après l'adresse et les
dépenses liées au chômage donc
effectivement quand on repousse l'âge de
la retraite bien évidemment on fait des
économies sur les retraites puisqu'on ne
paye pas des retraites à des gens que
l'on en aurait payé s'il n'avait pas eu
de report de l'âge mais ça provoque des
dépenses ailleurs
alors la dernière fois que l'on a
fait des calculs là-dessus le résultat
c'était si on repousse et si on gagne 1
en repoussantage il y a 0,33 qui part en
dépenses ailleurs
le problème c'est que c'était pour
beaucoup enfin le problème c'était pour
beaucoup des dépenses d'invalidité
d'accord or là la particularité de cette
de la réforme à la particularité la
différence entre la réforme aujourd'hui
et par exemple celle de 2010 c'est que
l'âge
d'ouverture des droits pour les
invalides et les inaptes ne sera pas
repoussée donc le 033 que nous avions
calculé n'est plus n'est plus valide
c'est à dire que on aura moins
d'économies sur les retraites puisque
les Invalides inapte ne seront pas
concernés mais en contrepartie on aura
moins de dépenses induite sur les
invalides et les inaptes parce qu'ils ne
sont pas conservés nous n'avons pas pu
refaire les travaux ainsi de suite mais
je pense que l'adresse et l'adresse
peuvent tout à fait vous fournir ces
données et je pense qu'elle devrait
figurant de certainement dans l'étude
dans l'étude d'impact voilà
par ailleurs j'insiste sur le fait que
une alors on le voit à travers les
dépenses une réforme des retraites ce
n'est pas en termes financier des
finances publiques qu'une que l'impact
sur le système de retraite parce que ça
peut avoir des effets sur des dépenses
ailleurs en retraite de même sur les
ressources quand vous faites une réforme
des retraites vous repoussez l'âge vous
vous espérez que les gens vont
travailler plus longtemps et et qu'il y
a plus de gens qui vont travailler donc
a priori ça fait plus de cotisations
retraite et je pense dans l'étude du
dossier de presse que cette surprise de
cotisation retraite a été intégrée mais
les gens qui travaillent ils ne payent
pas que des cotisations retraite il paye
des cotisations maladie il paye de
l'impôt sur le revenu il paye de la TVA
parce que s'il travaille plus il gagne
plus il ne compte plus d'accord donc
clairement
il faut faire un bilan élargi et ça
renvoie à d'autres questions et et on en
reparlera mais il faut clairement avoir
un bilan élargi parce qu'une réforme
retraite ce n'est pas qu'une réforme
retraite au niveau économique et au
niveau des et au niveau des des finances
publiques
sur les
sur les la question de Madame rise sur
les écarts entre les diverses
projections alors bien évidemment on ne
pose toujours ces questions mais entre
deux projections beaucoup de choses
bougent alors et franchement
heureusement les prévisions du
gouvernement bougent d'accord
rendez-vous compte que dans les pendant
l'épidémie covid on a fait des rapports
du corps à un moment où le gouvernement
a été très prudent et pensait que en
2020 on aurait moins 10% de PIB on a eu
moins 8 donc voilà donc c'était mieux
que après le gouvernement en 2021 il
prend il pensait une reprise de 5% de
PIB on a eu 8 d'accord donc
voilà
après il peut y avoir des mesures qui
ont été prises sur les retraites donc il
y a eu des sous-indexations sur les
retraites par rapport par rapport par
rapport au prix en 2019 et pour moins de
mesures en 2020 et bien ça avant que
c'était décidé nous on pouvait pas le
prendre en compte et puis il y a des
moments où il y a des changements
fondamentaux puisque tous les quatre ou
cinq ans tous les 5 ans l'Insee revoit
ses prévisions démographiques ce qui est
bien normal je veux dire elle tient
compte du fait que 50 sont passés que
donc on a plus d'informations et ainsi
de suite et donc par exemple c'était fin
2021 nous avons eu de nouvelles
projections démographiques de l'Insee
sachant que pour ce qui est des
projections démographiques c'est bien
évidemment pas les 40 membres du corps
qui se disent comment va évoluer la
fécondité la mortalité ainsi de suite
notre référence de base c'est le
scénario central de l'Insee donc
pourquoi les prévisions bougent bah je
vais dire c'est évident qu'elle doit
bouger et je serai inquiétant si elle ne
bougez pas et si vous avez vraiment de
la patience vous pouvez aller voir une
annexe
du rapport du corps où on ne fait
l'effort de chaque année on explique
tous les écarts par rapport à l'année
précédente et puis en explique
maintenant tous les écarts depuis 2016
d'accord donc vous verrez tout ce qui a
fait bouger
les dépenses les recettes depuis 2007
franchement
on le fait parce qu'il faut le faire et
parce qu'il faut rendre compte c'est
parce qu'il faut répondre à ce type de
question mais voilà c'est faut
s'accrocher parce que tout peut bouger
les prévisions du gouvernement les
hypothèses du corps les hypothèses de
l'INSEE sur la démographie il peut y
avoir des mesures et ainsi de suite
voilà sur l'emploi des seniors je pense
que
le message que que nous on voudrait
en gros le message que
pardon voilà un graphique qui est issu
du rapport du corps
le message qu'il y a derrière ce
graphique et je vais vous expliquer
après c'est un report de l'âge de de la
retraite déplace le problème de l'emploi
des seniors mais ne l'aggrave pas
qu'est-ce que dit ce graphique alors
d'une part c'est sur le passé bien
évidemment c'est ce qui s'est passé
depuis un gros 2010 donc l'âge de la
retraite c'est progressivement décalé
avec la réforme de report de l'âge légal
de 60 à 62 et puis avec la réforme dite
Touraine où on augmente
la durée de cotisation nécessaire donc
l'âge de départ à la retraite en orange
il s'est décalé vers le haut d'accord et
vous voyez que l'âge de sortie de
l'activité en bleu et l'âge de sortie de
l'emploi en verre ce sont décalés de
manière quasiment parallèle d'accord
donc l'idée c'est quand on repousse
l'âge ça tire à la fois la sortie de
l'emploi et la sortie de l'activité
donc ça c'est le résultat fondamental
alors bien évidemment précaution d'usage
c'est pas parce que ça s'est passé dans
le passé que ça va se reproduire dans
l'avenir voilà passer de 60 à 62 c'est
pas comme passer de 62 à 64 mais voilà
ce qu'on dit en tout cas est-ce qu'on
peut dire sur le passé moi je ne suis
pas Madame Irma je peux pas dire pour le
plus c'est un
alors c'est à peu près admis on a des
travaux de Michael Zemmour qui seraient
plus qui sont en accord avec cette
tendance fondamentale mais qui lui voit
qui parce que là c'est la moyenne donc
lui il le voit en regardant les diverses
catégories et là est sur il y aurait des
différenciations dans cette évolution
moyenne selon les catégories et avec des
évolutions plus défavorables pour les
ouvriers les employés que pour les
cadres mais voilà en gros le message sur
l'emploi des seniors
donc les questions en termes d'emploi
qui sont les plus controversés sur les
retraites ça me semble être parce qu'en
gros le message là c'est en gros quand
on repousse l'âge on stabilise les
situations c'est à dire que ceux qui
sont en emploi vont
pour ça que l'employeur quand on
repousse l'âge il va pas les licencier
et ceux qui sont en emploi certains
peuvent continuer à travailler et donc
ils vont continuer donc on va un peu
figer les situations sachant que ceux
qui sont au chômage vont pas pour autant
rendre des difficultés à retrouver de
l'emploi donc il y a donc le report de
l'âge aboutit au maintien à l'emploi des
seniors d'accord donc il y a plus de
seniors qui travaillent après un rapport
de l'âge alors la question qui se pose
c'est
qu'elle est et ça me permettra aussi de
répondre à une question sur les
projections de la DG trésor quel est
l'effet sur les autres c'est à dire ceux
qui ne sont pas seniors parce que
on peut se dire si on maintient un
emploi des seniors il y aura un effet
sur les autres d'accord alors attention
à long terme à long terme il y a
consensus sur la plupart des économistes
à long terme quand l'économie est en
équilibre le travail des seniors n'est
pas l'ennemi de l'emploi des jeunes et
le travail n'est pas un gâteau que l'on
partage et donc s'il est au Seigneur
travaille et ça veut dire que les gens
nous travaillent pas au contraire au
contraire et je vous montre un graphe
qui illustre ça au contraire vous le
voyez là c'est dans les pays où les
seniors travaillent le plus
que les jeunes travaillent le plus aussi
d'accord c'est plus loin
donc ça à long terme à long terme il n'y
a pas
il me semble qu'il y ait un consensus
le travail n'est pas un gâteau que l'on
partage je laisse le travail des seniors
n'est pas l'ennemi du travail des jeunes
la question elle se pose à court terme
et si j'en parle c'est parce qu'elle
s'est posée dans une séance du corps au
début de l'année 2022 où on a eu à
elle s'est posée début 2022 dans une
séance qui a été un peu consacrée à ça
parce que à court terme vous avez
des gens qui racontent l'histoire
suivante
quand je fais une réforme des retraites
je contraigne où j'amène des seniors à
rester en poste sur le marché de
l'emploi d'accord donc c'est un choc
positif sur d'offres sur le marché du
travail quand il y a un choc positif
d'offre sur un marché normalement les
prix baissent et dans la l'occurrence
c'est les salaires
comme on est sur un marché un peu
particulier la baisse des salaires c'est
un peu problématique et donc
l'histoire qui racontait mais c'est
l'histoire qui est sous-jacente certains
modèles économiques c'est et bien dans
un premier temps ça augmente le chômage
après avoir augmenté le chômage ça pèse
sur les salaires et après on revient à
l'équilibre et là on revient au moment
où l'emploi des seniors n'est pas
l'ennemi du travail des jeunes d'accord
et
jusqu'à cette séance de janvier 2022 les
deux modèles qui étaient utilisés qu'on
avait utilisé deux ou trois ans avant
pour pour faire des hypothèses sur
un report de l'âge le modèle mésange du
Trésor et le modèle
OSCE aboutissait en gros au même
résultat d'accord c'est à dire à long
terme on revient à l'équilibre pas de
problème à court terme un effet négatif
sur le chômage ainsi de suite
en janvier donc pour moi ça me
paraissait une donnée acquise de de la
science et un consensus en janvier 2022
ce consensus
a été brisé et donc je suis obligé de
vous dire que c'est une question
controversée maintenant puisque le
trésor nous a dit nous pour projeter une
réforme des retraites en utilisent plus
le modèle mésange on considère que ce
modèle macroquénésien qui n'est pas
adapté d'accord et il est Makro kunisien
comme le modèle de l'autre de l'OSCE et
donc à l'époque et bien alors que avant
globalement le trésor et l'OSCE délivrés
de même message à partir de cette séance
de janvier 2002 au Loste et le trésor
n'ont pas délivré le même message et
donc vous voyez là on vous montre
ce que donnait les résultats avec le
modèle mésange avec le modèle mésange
donc c'est ce qui a le plus à droite et
puisque donne la nouvelle approche du
trésor qu'ils ont baptisé eux-mêmes une
approche comptable d'accord et vous
voyez l'écart qui est significatif alors
surtout surtout à court terme alors à
court terme dans une réforme des
retraites c'est 5 ans parce que d'une
réforme de retraite de toute façon elle
est même pas fini dans 5 ans mais vous
voyez que avec l'approche keynévienne
ancienne de ménage de mésange ou que
avec l'approche toujours actuelle du
modèle de l'OSCE au bout de cinq ans on
a un surcroît depuis de 0 et on a une
amélioration globale des finances
publiques de 01 points de pipe
c'est-à-dire 2,5 milliards et que
maintenant avec l'approche comptable on
a 0,9 points de PIB
et on a une amélioration des finances
publiques de 06 d'accord moi franchement
je ne vais pas trancher cette
controverse
nous avons assisté à ce débat lors d'une
réunion donc de janvier 2022 nous en
avons rendu compte dans leur rapport du
corps en septembre 2022 bien évidemment
ça dépasse mes compétences que de tracer
cette controverse
il est clair que en tout cas ne
semble-t-il même si le dossier de presse
actuellement ne comporte pas d'éléments
sur les conséquences macroéconomiques de
la réforme des retraites vous avez un
bilan à la fin qui est un bilan
financier retraite mais vous n'avez pas
ça aura tel impact sur le PIB sera
impact sur le chômage sur le commerce
extérieur sur le revenu disponible des
ménages ainsi de suite il me semble que
ce qui est la référence du gouvernement
c'est ce qui est dénommé sur ce tableau
l'approche comptable ça me permet de
répondre à d'autres questions sur ce que
je pense de la des trésor franchement je
pense pas trop puisque il y a une
controverse et donc je on en remet à
plus sachant que moi sur ces questions
et à votre commission qui qui va
sûrement éclaircir ces éléments là
alors après quelques réactions sur les
scénarios le scénario le plus
défavorable c'est le scénario à 0,7 % et
c'est effectivement l'évolution de la
productivité qu'on a eu sur les 10 ans
d'accord rien à dire mais nous on
projette à 50 ans et quand je suis comme
ça un peu pessimiste en me disant ça a
été mauvais pendant les 10 dernières
années et ça va l'être pendant 50 ans je
vais sur internet et je vais voir ce que
font mes homologues américains mes
homologues américains alors attention
c'est pas le corps avec des partenaires
sociaux aux États-Unis ça s'appelle un
Border et donc vous avez des économistes
et des voilà et eux ils font aussi des
projections parce qu'il y a un système
de retraite et de sécurité sociale aux
États-Unis et ce qui me fascine toujours
c'est que le scénario central de nos
amis américains qui disent comme vous
depuis 10 ans on a une productivité du
travail qui est à 07 le note ils sont
pas ils sont pas plus bêtes que nous ils
disent mais nous vous êtes à 50 ans donc
regarde les grandes évolutions et donc
notre scénario central il est à insiste
ce qui ce qui est amusant puisque c'est
notre scénario eau donc les Américains
sont certainement des optimistes des
naïfs qui croient aux progrès
technologiques à l'innovation et ainsi
de suite et nous on est beaucoup plus
pessimiste là aussi comme je vous l'ai
dit le corps donne 4 hypothèses il n'en
privilégie aucune le gouvernement était
sur un 3 il y a cinq ans il est passé à
1 comme référence dans cette réforme là
aussi c'est un des éléments du débat
c'est un des éléments central mais c'est
à vous de savoir si vous vous placez du
côté parce que c'est un choix je veux
dire franchement je suis pas Madame Irma
et je sais pas ce qui va se passer en
termes d'innovation non non mais même
monsieur donc je ne suis pas donc je
n'en sais rien c'est pour ça que moi je
vous présente des choses avec quatre
hypothèses en disant je n'en privilégie
aucune mais comme bien évidemment quand
on fait une réforme et c'est votre
responsabilité il faut faire un choix de
référence et bien si vous voulez
discuter de cette question
lisez on a fait un colloque sur ce sujet
en 2021 donc du corps donc les diverses
positions et lisez aussi ce qui se fait
au niveau américain et ce qui se fait
aussi au niveau européen puisque il y a
un âge en gros
l'Union européenne fait aussi des
projections des dépenses liées au
vieillissement vieillesse famille
maladie et ainsi de suite et eux leur
scénario de référence à long terme c'est
plutôt un 4 un 5 d'accord donc voilà ce
que je peux vous donner comme
information sur
sur les sur les
sur les scénarios
interrompre le président mais non mais
c'est pas ça c'est que là tout le monde
piétine ils ont des tas de questions et
des observations et je pense avec
l'accord du président concret je pense
que il faut qu'on passe quand même aux
orateurs de groupe et aux questions de
députés qui sont nombreuses donc je vous
ne manquerai pas de revenir de toute
façon sur certains thématiques que vous
avez abordées
bien sûr alors soyez synthétiques et je
vais demander autant à monsieur le
Président du cordes vous répondent de
manière synthétique en tous les cas on a
donné nombreuses questions donc tout de
suite la parole a pris ce cas Thévenot
pour le groupe renaissance pour deux
minutes
c'est pas comme
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
Madame madame monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président du corps Monsieur
le Secrétaire général mes chers
collègues je vais essayer effectivement
essayer d'aller très vite je vous
remercie pour les éléments que vous avez
décrit amené rapporter expliquer si les
conclusions effectivement du corps sont
publiques et libres d'accès forte
constater que le rapport a été sujet de
très nombreuses contre vérités ces
derniers temps et je pense qu'elles
doivent être mises au clair aujourd'hui
dans le cadre de cette audition que je
salue en effet nombre de mes collègues
de la France insoumise disent à loisir
ou peut-être par paresse que la réforme
telle que proposée par le gouvernement
n'était pas utile puisque son long leur
interprétation de vos conclusions il
suffirait de réduire le chômage pour
financer notre système de retraite par
répartition hors point important
souligner d'ailleurs dans votre rapport
sans réforme de vote de notre part ce
seront 500 milliards d'euros de dettes
cumulé qui seront
vus sur 25 ans ce montant important est
malheureusement aussi le plus optimiste
car il s'inscrit dans l'atteinte de
l'objectif du plein emploi je tiens ici
à rappeler qu'avant 2017 le chômage
atteignait 10% et que depuis c'est grâce
à l'action de la majorité présidentielle
que l'objectif du plein d'emploi est en
passe d'être attein et figure d'ailleurs
dans vos conclusions alors oui loin de
moi l'idée de ne parler que de la
majorité je peux aussi rappeler que le
programme de la France insoumise qui
veut punir toutes les structures créant
de la valeur ou tout comme le celui du
rassemblement national qui d'ailleurs
change de position au gré des vents
d'opinion conduirait à détruire des
emplois et donc elle l'effondrement de
nos finances à cela on peut ajouter que
l'enjeu alors que les Français ne
seraient pas ne seraient pas comment
sécuriser nos retraites deviendraient
comment trouver un emploi
afin d'avoir une vision globale de
l'ensemble des scénarios possibles
j'aimerais donc messieurs vous poser la
question suivante
comment réagit la dette à l'hypothèse du
taux de chômage
très bien Madame la Députée tout de
suite la parole et tout rassemblement
national pour Thomas ménager deux
minutes
faudrait mettre le micro monsieur le
député monsieur le député votre micro
n'est pas ouvert
je propose que le temps que vous régliez
votre problème technique on passe au
suivant Véronique louvagi pour les
républicains
je vous donne le micro
oui merci merci monsieur le Président
merci Madame l'après-midi merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président bras pour la
présentation que vous avez pu nous faire
j'ai 4 questions une première question
sur l'effet de l'évolution de la
natalité est-ce que vous pourriez nous
donner quelques éléments puisque nous
connaissons depuis quelques jours le
taux de natalité publié par l'Insee à
1,8 enfants par femme quelle serait par
exemple l'impact d'un niveau de natalité
de deux enfants par femme puisque vous
nous faites des prévisions à 50 ans une
deuxième question sur la Cadès puisque
vous avez intégré dans un des tableaux
la prise en compte du patrimoine de la
Cadès en l'occurrence un solde de dette
qui reste la Cadès a priait en charge la
dette covid est-ce qu'il y aurait pu
avoir un autre effet si la dette covid
n'avait pas été prise en charge par la
Cadès puisque la cadette c'est toujours
alimentée par la CRDS c'est ce qu'il y
avait là une piste une troisième
question sur l'effet de l'indexation des
sur l'inflation quel serait l'impact
d'une décision d'indexation des pensions
sur les salaires en termes de
répercussions et la quatrième question
est-ce que vous disposez au niveau du
corps d'éléments relatifs à la
répartition des montants de pension par
retraité avec des indications entre les
hommes et les femmes et quelle est
l'évolution de cette répartition dans le
temps je vous remercie merci je crois
que Thomas ménager a récupéré sur son
micro
oui merci monsieur le Président et
excusez-moi pour ce petit problème
technique monsieur le Président du corps
Monsieur le Secrétaire général je vous
remercie tout d'abord de votre présence
devant cette commission afin d'apporter
des éclaircissements bienvenue sur votre
appareil vos derniers votre dernier
rapport fait l'objet de toute notre
attention dans la mesure où c'est quasi
exclusivement sur cette base que le
gouvernement entend défendre sa réforme
des retraites qu'une très large majorité
des Français juges injuste et
injustifiée et les manifestations en
cours le prouvent lors de la
présentation de la réforme Elizabeth
borne a déclaré je cite les chiffres
sont là ils sont implacables on ne peut
plus laisser filer la dette pourtant
page 9 de votre rapport et vous venez de
le redire vous indiquez que vos travaux
ne valide pas le bien fondé les discours
qui mettent en avant l'idée d'une
dynamique non contrôlée des dépenses de
retraite contredisant un site totalement
les propos alarmiste de la première
ministre aussi une question simple pour
commencer que pensez-vous de ce
détournement de vos travaux à défendre
purement politiciennes un peu plus loin
dans votre rapport page 133 exactement
vous alerter sur les précautions
méthodologiques dans l'interprétation de
vos projections vous précisez en effet
que vos projections ne rendent pas
compte de l'effet global des finances
publiques ça a été dit vous indiquez je
cite qu'un relèvement des droits aurait
un impact à la hausse sur les dépenses
sociales hors retraite chômage minima
sociaux invalidité chiffré d'ores et
déjà 4 milliards pour un passage de 62 à
64 ans c'est observation n'est pas
nouvelle on le retrouve dans le rapport
de la Cour des comptes de 2020 T1 pour
la réforme verte qui a indiqué qu'une
explosion de 3 milliards des dépenses
sociales en 2017 pourtant aucune trace
de ces données dans la présentation de
la réforme et je m'étonne que ces
informations très intéressantes soient
totalement mis sous le tapis par le
gouvernement qui semble faire ses
courses avec les données de votre
rapport pour me retenir au terme d'une
lecture particulièrement fallacieuse que
les éléments propres à justifier la
légitimité de sa réforme injuste vous le
constatez d'après vos propos aussi
j'insiste regrettez-vous de cette
approche gouvernementale malhonnête qui
élue de la vision macroéconomique avec
les implications sur l'ensemble de nos
finances publiques et non sur le seul
équilibre du système de retraite la
question est là je vous remercie
merci bien la parole à présent est à
Monsieur Pascal Lecamp pour le modem et
indépendant
il doit être en visio
très bien
merci Monsieur des représentants du
corps et surtout pour votre introduction
et au premier réponse très éclairantes
vos travaux doivent permettre d'avancer
collectivement dans un débat éclairé
c'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui je crois
que c'est ce que les Français attendent
de nous
salue donc le Portugais de cette
audition j'aurais en ce qui me concerne
deux interrogations ce qui concerne le
modèle d'ailleurs qui iront j'espère
dans ce sens en premier lieu nous sommes
favorables à des mesures permettant une
retraite progressive qui éviterait
l'écartement parfois abrupte
des seigneurs du marché du travail je
souhaiterais donc savoir comment vous
estimez l'impact d'une hausse du taux
d'emploi des seniors d'un point sur les
recettes sociales et donc l'équilibre du
système et dans ce cas là vous
semblerait-il utile d'inclure une clause
de revoyure dans le texte de la réforme
des retraites que nous apprêtons à
l'examiner en second lieu vous retenez
deux conventions vous nous la rappelez
pour l'évaluation des perspectives de
soldes du système de retraite avec d'une
part l'équilibre permanent des régimes
publics dit EPR qui prévoit que l'État
cotise simplement pour équilibrer ses
régimes ce qui est logique et la
convention effort de l'État constant dit
EC qui prévoit que l'État continue de
surcotiser alors même que ces régimes
seraient excédentaires quand la masse
salariale des régimes publics devrait
baisser dans les prochaines années vous
nous l'avez rappelé ainsi la convention
dit EPR vers logiquement une baisse de
la contribution de l'État à l'équilibre
du système
il me semble ainsi que l'équilibre du
système à partir de 2043 permis par la
Convention EC n'est que cosmétique et
qu'un déficit aggravé de l'État venant
combler le déficit du système de
retraite
qui viendrait donc combler des systèmes
de retraite quel regard portez-vous sur
ce sujet merci merci alors il y avait je
crois Arthur de la porte mais je ne
crois pas qu'il soit connecté donc
qu'est-ce qu'il y a quelqu'un d'autre
pour le groupe socialiste
Messieurs les Présidents et Messieurs
les vapoteurs écoutez monsieur d'abord
n'est pas là mais merci
explications c'est prélevé
ces appuis aussi qui vont nous aider à
débattre mais dites moi au delà de la
polémique y aurait-il une autre
proposition à faire au français quelque
chose de moins brutal ça pourrait nous
aider vu que vous avez des spécialistes
vous êtes des spécialistes et nous les
élus les abordons avec disons à l'idée
la souffrance des personnes
la souffrance de la population et faire
travailler jusqu'à 650 pardon à 64 ans
65 ans 65 ans c'est juste pour faire
passer la chose mais c'était l'objectif
est 65 ans est-ce qu'on pourrait
envisager non seulement quelque chose
qui permettrait aux aînés de rester au
travail en activité vu que nous sommes
dans une économie et en même temps
permettre à l'État de faire un effort on
sait bien que ces économies qui seront
réalisées sont là pour faire d'autres
politiques publiques au-delà de l'effort
de l'État
merci merci bien la parole est à Paul
Christophe pour le groupe horizon
est-il oui voilà chers
sur les effets du relevant de l'âge de
départ
je pense que Samuel quelques
éclaircissements on regarde ce que l'on
peut entendre aujourd'hui
l'allongement de la durée d'activité de
génération plus âgée aurait-il pour
conséquence de retarder l'Oxy au marché
du travail donc pour les jeunes je me
souviens pour avoir lu le rapport en
2016 vous jugez peu probable la
causalité entre chômage des jeunes et
emploi des seniors à cette même époque
d'ailleurs en vous basant donc sur sur
les travaux du Trésor vous affirmiez que
des hausses à 63 64 et 65 ans positif
sur l'activité économique vous estimiez
que l'impact de chaque relèvement serait
une hausse de 0,7 points du PIB une
création de 2
dans des collègues il y a un petit
cousin un petit problème avec votre
micro là
[Musique]
bon je propose qu'on passe au
à Sébastien Petavy on reviendra sur Paul
Christophe
bonjour monsieur le Président le groupe
vous m'entendez bien
le groupe écologiste les moi-même vous
remercions pour votre éclairage précieux
dans le cadre de l'étude de cette
réforme des retraites qui une fois de
plus se cantonnent à brandir
l'épouvantail de l'équilibre budgétaire
pour demander un justement des efforts
au plus vulnérables alors tout d'abord
les projections du corps sont notamment
basées sur les prévisions du
gouvernement pour les 5 prochaines
années qui prévoit de façon très
optimiste un taux de chômage à 5% en
2027 ces deux points de mieux que la
cible retenue par le corps en 2032 ce
qui fasse les prévisions pour la période
2027 2037 alors que l'argument principal
de cette réforme du retour à l'équilibre
budgétaire semble donc basé sur un
scénario erroné avez-vous entamé de
nouvelles réflexions face à ce constat
de plus en ayant recours à votre
simulateur d'impact avec un scénario de
chômage à 4,5%. le déficit du régime ne
serait que de 0,4% du PIB en 2030 soit
10 milliards d'euros alors que le
gouvernement annonce quant à lui un
déficit de 13,5 milliards d'euros d'ici
2030 pouvaient de vous nous sur le
montant exact du site prévu pour 2030
votre rapport prévoit également une
diminution relative du niveau de vie des
retraités par rapport au reste de la
population qui serait lié à la
stabilisation diminution de la part des
dépenses de retraite dans le PIB aussi
le corps évaluche le niveau de vie en
prenant en compte le patrimoine
financier patrimoine immobilier et
l'endettement sur cette baisse du niveau
de vie notre groupe soit très aussi
connaître quels sont vos prévisions
concernant la baisse spécifique des
pensions d'ici 2070 indépend vraiment
des autres revenus concernant les autres
mesures annoncées le gouvernement
prévoit notamment une revalorisation de
la pension minimale à 85% du SMIC pour
les assurer ayant effectué une carrière
complète et n'ayant jamais dépassé le
SMIC mais un rapport de 2018 sur la
trajectoire professionnelle de 2,5
millions de personnes pendant 21 ans à
évaluer que seuls 48 personnes n'avait
pas d'être passé le SMIC pendant cette
période ainsi pouvons nous évaluer
combien de personnes seraient réellement
touchées par cette mesure et enfin
l'index seniors prévu dans le projet de
loi aura-t-il un impact concret sur
l'amélioration de l'activité des seniors
car on ne peut député merci monsieur le
député Xavier deux minutes il y a encore
beaucoup de questions
tiens le dire à mes collègues nous avons
encore deux orateurs de groupe et
ensuite nous avons 8 ou 9 questions donc
je vais vous demander pour les questions
de d'aller vraiment droite au but c'est
à dire une minute vous posez directement
la question et ensuite on donne la
parole au président pour pouvoir
répondre donc je passe la parole tout de
suite à Karine Lebon pour la Gauche
démocrate et républicaine ensuite pour
le groupe loyotte tu auras Charles de
Courson je crois qu'il est effectivement
en ligne et ensuite monsieur Bazin qui
doit partir pour pouvoir intervenir et
on poursuit la liste tout à l'heure qui
était ce projet il était prêt à parler
j'ai pas lequel nous on avait c'est
Pierre
le président du corps je rattraperai le
début de votre propos que j'ai pas pu
entendre puisque j'étais dans une grande
manifestation à Marseille
où les gens de protestaient pas contre
votre rapport rassurez-vous c'est plutôt
contre la réforme qui protestait
simplement dans beaucoup de questions
déjà été posées ça m'avait évoqué un
certain nombre j'ai bien noté les
précautions que vous prenez de manière à
ce que votre rapport ne soit pas
mentalisé de quelques manières que ce
soit en indiquant d'ailleurs que s'il
est légitime de défendre les niveaux
actuels et futurs des dépenses de
retraite H2 départ à la retraite ou
encore le niveau de vie des retraités
qu'il serait trop ou pas assez élevé
selon les préférences politiques le
rapport annuel du corps n'a pas pour
mission dites-vous de refléter ces
débats j'ai noté également effectivement
cette formule page 9 les résultats ne se
rapportent ne valide pas le bien fondé
des discours qui mettent en avant l'idée
d'une dynamique non contrôlée des
dépenses des retraites je pense que nous
avons tout intérêt à ce que vous
puissiez exposer ici et ailleurs
clairement les données que nous
puissions discuter sur de base saines et
qui soit les mêmes pour pour tous ma
question portera sur les évaluations que
vous avez faites concernant la période
2028 2032 vous évoquez les changements
que vous avez été amenés à faire dans
vos schémas et initiaux sur ce sujet là
et vous employez le mot d'artefact en
disant que les calculs que vous avez
fait ce fond de Ré sur sur des artefacts
j'aimerais en savoir un petit peu plus
sur la façon dont vous avez
procéder pour produire ces analyses
concernant notamment cette période je
vous remercie merci bien et donc la
parole est à Charles de Courson pour le
groupe yacht deux minutes et ensuite on
passe aux questions de députés merci
[Musique]
que ce soit les les réserves puisque la
moitié c'est des réserves argées Arrco
il y a aussi toutes les réserves une
quarantaine de milliards des différents
régimes des libéraux ils sont propriétés
des assurés est-ce que vous avez fait
une analyse juridique de qui est
propriétaire de ces réserves
juste
est-ce que parce qu'on lui a coupé le
sifflet tout à l'heure est-ce que Paul
Christophe a retrouvé sur du son
parce que j'aurais pas
des avantages et le groupe horizon
bon donc si vous passe la question vous
pourrez pardon monsieur bazar doit
partir donc vous proposez
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente deux questions sur
l'inflation elle est très faible en 2021
elle est beaucoup plus forte en 2022 et
potentiellement importantes encore en
est-ce que l'évolution relative du
niveau de vie des pensionné celle des
actifs dans les salaires peuvent ne pas
suivre parfaitement l'inflation ne
change pas un peu vos prévisions telles
que présentées deuxième sujet le déclin
de natalité ma collègue Veronique
clovagy appréhendait cette question mais
est-ce que pour vous c'est une fatalité
inéluctable et une hypothèse fixe ou une
politique publique pourrait-elle
impacter l'hypothèse retenue et donc vos
hypothèses d'équilibre à moyen terme
ce qu'on propose on va on va déroger un
peu on vient de s'entendre tous les deux
ce que pas de monde doit partir en
séance là on a une liste on propose de
la chlore dans ce qui suivent on vous
propose là vous passe la parole vous
accédez pas une minute et si la question
a déjà été posée merci de ne pas la
reposer quoi donc Mathieu Lefebvre merci
monsieur le Président bon moi je retiens
votre intervention que nous sommes face
à un problème de physique élémentaire
vous l'avez dit qu'il devrait je crois
appeler à la raison de ceux qui
considèrent un tant soit peu la science
dans notre pays et de ce point de vue je
crois qu'il faut appeler un chat un chat
un déficit qui augmente ça n'est ni plus
ni moins qu'un dérapage vous l'avez dit
vous réalisez vos prévisions à partir de
4 scénarios qui reposent à la fois sur
la productivité du travail et
l'évolution du taux moyen de chômage moi
ma question elle est elle est très
simple quel serait les perspectives
d'équilibre avec le taux de chômage
actuel de 7,3% et la productivité du
travail actuel qui est légèrement
supérieur à 1 du point de vue de je vous
remercie merci Benoît Bournay
merci monsieur le président madame la
Présidente merci pour le l'audition le
corps donc avocat sur la partager le
diagnostic et on voit bien que tout ça
n'est pas encore extrêmement clair
est-ce que vous pourriez nous confirmer
que la convention EPR va être celle
centrale retenue dans laquelle je
rappelle l'état compense les régimes
spéciaux et c'est son propre régime
public et je pense que ça ferait du bien
à tout le monde devrait entendre que
dans cette convention il y a bien un
déficit projeté à horizon 2027 et 2030
deuxième élément sur le fait de
présenter les choses en pourcentage du
pipsé très intéressant alors je vais
vous suivre même si ça ne dit rien du
solde et quand on regarde un peu ce qui
s'est passé dans les 20 dernières années
en 2001 le corps effectivement prévoyait
que les retraits dans le pipe soient nos
moins de 14% donc vous aviez bien vu
sauf qu'entre temps on a eu les réformes
2003 2008 2010 et 2014 donc est-ce que
le corps dans ses prévisions ne se
trouve pas toujours un peu optimiste
merci Monsieur Paul André Colombani
il est là en visio peut-être
non bon Félicie Girard horizon merci
monsieur
le précalin à 64 ans là je l'égale de
départ en retraite et en amenant la
durée de cotisation à 43 à nuités selon
vos prévisions l'équilibre financier du
système est-il rétabli si oui dans
quelle temporalité et surtout ces
mesures seront-elles suffisantes pour
garantir l'équilibre financier à long
terme ou faudra-t-il dans les dessiner
décennies à venir pardon décaler à
nouveau l'âge de départ à la retraite
par ailleurs dans le cadre de la réforme
des retraites augmenter le pourcentage
d'actifs chez les plus de 55 ans est un
enjeu majeur quel est votre analyse de
l'impact sur ces de cette réforme sur
l'emploi des seniors dans notre pays
pensez-vous que les paramètres que
proposent aujourd'hui la réforme soumise
à débat permettront d'accompagner au
mieux les seniors et si je peux me
permettre je pose la question de Paul
Christophe donc c'est une question sur
les effets du relèvement de l'âge de
départ à la retraite quant au chômage
des jeunes l'allongement de la durée
d'activité des générations plus âgées
auraient-ils pour conséquence de
retarder l'accès au marché du travail
des jeunes en 2016 le corps jugé peu
probable à causalité entre le chômage
des jeunes et emploie des seniors 6 ans
plus tard le corps reste-t-il sur cette
lecture je vous remercie merci
Eric à lozet merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président du corps dans vos
projections vous avez intégré et c'est
bien normal les effets de la réforme
Touraine voté en 2016 il y a 6 ans
réforme que j'ai voté avec la majorité
VRPs de l'époque autrement dit avec le
temps il faudra cotiser 5 trimestres
supplémentaires par rapport aux
conditions de départ des retraités qui
partent aujourd'hui si bien que la
situation de référence à partir de
laquelle vous avez effectué vos
projections et différentes de la
situation actuelle
des conditions de départ à la retraite
c'est bien normal aussi cette réforme a
une conséquence sensible sur l'âge de
départ à la retraite sachant qu'il est
déjà monté en moyenne après de 63 ans
actuellement je parle de moyenne
effectivement en prenant en compte les
effets de la totalité de la réforme
Touraine et les 5 trimestres qui
s'agiteront progressivement dans les
années à venir l'âge de départ
s'approche ton anciennement des 64 ans
une évolution qui se produit donc or
nouvelle réforme et qui conduit à
regarder un peu différemment le report
officiel de l'âge à 64 ans pouvez-vous
me confirmer que les projections
réalisées prennent déjà en compte un âge
moyen de départ à 64 ans avec les
conséquences financières liées en
recettes et en dépense et êtes-vous en
situation et en capacité le corps de
pouvoir apprécier cette situation et de
l'intégrer dans vos analyses
un évidal
c'est bon merci monsieur le président
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président du corps dans le rapport
annuel du corps vous soulignez que le
vieillissement de la population va
entraîner et c'est bien logique un
nombre de cotisants en diminution par
rapport au nombre de un nombre de
personnes par rapport au nombre de
retraite à verser et c'est logique
puisque le nombre de personnes de 75 à
84 ans va enregistrer une croissance
inédite de près de 50% entre 2020 et
2030 vous précisez aussi que la
situation financière du système de
retraite se détériore avec un déficit de
12 à 20 milliards selon la convention et
les scénarios projetés et cela de
manière durable sur les 25 prochaines
années aussi dans ce contexte de
transition démographique importante
auxquelles s'adjoint un climat
économique flûte tuant marqué par la par
l'inflation quelle est la trajectoire
dont l'impact sur l'équilibre de notre
système de retraite par répartition sera
le plus efficace en maintenant bien
évidemment les objectifs cibles de
croissance des dépenses publiques merci
bien Manon la député madame Fanta
Peretti
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président dans votre rapport je me suis
intéressée aux hypothèses démographiques
notamment les hypothèses de fécondité et
de soldes migratoires vaut 4 scénarios
ont été bâtis en fonction d'hypothèse
qui correspondent au départ économique
actuel je pense qu'il convient aussi de
prendre en compte les débats autour de
la politique de natalité et de la
politique migratoire d'un côté votre
rapport reprend les données de l'INSEE
sur une fécondité en baisse ce qui
pourra augmenter la part des dépenses
des retraites dans le PIB aujourd'hui
certains plaids pour une politique de
natalité à l'image du haut-commissaire
au plan néanmoins on enverrait les
effets que dans une vingtaine d'années
de l'autre l'Insee voit le solde
migratoire en baisse 20000 personnes par
an ce qui augmenterait aussi la part des
dépenses des retraites dans le PIB pour
les scénarios à 0,7 ou à 1%. or une
politique migratoire très soutenue comme
en Allemagne permettrait d'embaucher des
travailleurs qui seront immédiatement
des contributeurs nets au des retraites
c'est certes un choix politique qui
pourrait en déranger certains mais qui
répondrai à un double besoin pour notre
pays qui
si on tient compte du monde de
ressources actuelles ma question donc la
suivante dans vos prochaines projections
pour affiner vos scénarios pourriez-vous
envisager d'intégrer à vos hypothèses
ces dimensions qui pourraient que
pourraient avoir les politiques
migratoires et de natalité
Serge Muller
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président du corps mes chers collègues
afin d'équilibrer le système des
retraites l'État verse des sommes
permettant de faire face aux déficit
structurel dans le montant est égal à la
différence entre le niveau d'équilibre
et le niveau sans versement le montant
de ces subventions équilibre diminue
année après année car elles assurent
l'équilibre des régimes en voie de
disparition ou de réduction des
effectifs comme ceux de la SNCF la RATP
les marins les mineurs ou encore les
cigarettes cela implique de décider du
niveau d'intervention de l'État avec un
niveau de productivité du travail à un 6
me confirmez-vous que réinvestir cet
argent public dans le système de
retraite
permettrait à notre système de retraite
actuel d'être à l'équilibre sans réforme
supplémentaire jusqu'en 2045 seconde
question quelles sont les conditions de
possibilités de ce niveau de
productivité du travail je vous remercie
merci Nicolas sensu en visio je pense
Cléder s'il est toujours là
il est pas là mais moi j'avais une
dernière question à vous poser que j'ai
oublié tout à l'heure c'est un peu la
question inverse de mon
excellent collègue Benoît mournay en
2019 si je me trompe pas dans les
prévisions vous annonciez pour cette
année un déficit de 0,5% du PIB on a un
excédent de 3,2 milliards donc
j'aimerais savoir
à quoi vous attribuez ça et qu'est-ce
que ça induit et enfin le corps à
chiffrer a-t-il chiffré l'incidence d'un
rétablissement d'un hdgal de 60 ans
soutenu par 68% des Français notamment
les économies pour l'assurance chômage
la branche des actions du travail et
maladie professionnelle je voudrais
savoir s'il y a ces scénario là ont été
étudiés par le corps merci
allez-y président
donc il y a eu des questions sur le fait
les résultats du corps en 2001 en 2019
en 2018 ne sont pas les résultats du
corps en 2021 enfin 2022 je vous l'ai
dit tout à l'heure c'est normal parce
que le monde évolue et que nous prenons
en compte en règle générale complètement
le passé d'accord et que même les
hypothèses sur le futur peuvent changer
les hypothèses à court terme du
gouvernement et donner des exemples
peuvent changer et je le répète nous
sommes
variions pas des hypothèses du
gouvernement pour les premières années
d'accord que nous hypothèses à nous à
long terme peuvent changer également
nous avons décalé les scénarios de
productivité par rapport à ailleurs donc
les choses ne sont pas toujours les
mêmes et si vous voulez faire le travail
notarial pourquoi
en 2016 c'est différent de 2022 ce
travail est fait il est à l'annexe
franchement c'est pas passionnant mais
si vous voulez vous pouvez alors on y
remonté jusqu'en 2016 sur 2001
franchement je ne sais pas et là ça
serait un travail notarial et de
bénédictin que je ne vais pas imposer à
la petite équipe qui a encore on a des
choses plus intéressantes à faire voilà
sur âge légal à 60 ans nous ne l'avons
pas fait voilà
mais attention nous n'avons pas fait
je ne suis pas le corps moi si demain
on me dit les membres du corps me disent
on veut avoir cette simulation je me
retourne parce que bien évidemment c'est
pas nous qui fait comme tout on se
retourne vers les régimes de retraite
vers les administrations on dira ben
voilà donc il n'y a pas de problème
a priori au corps pour faire telle ou
tel analyse d'accord nous nous avons un
programme de travail et on est prêt à
mettre dans le programme de travail ce
que les membres du corps et je vous les
ai cités au début nous nous demanderons
sur les questions
démographiques natalité sur le
migratoire donc là aussi
nous n'allons pas à 42 membres faire des
projets de l'hypothèses démographiques
qui viendraient d'un débat entre la CGT
la CFDT le Medef en député Renaissance
un député
LR ainsi de suite bon nous sommes calés
sur les hypothèses de l'Insee qui
d'ailleurs servent de base à tous les
travaux c'est-à-dire que toutes les tous
les travaux que vous avez en termes de
projection économique et ainsi de suite
sont basées sur les hypothèses de
l'Insee c'est pas avec moi qu'il faut
les discuter d'accord après ce que nous
faisons encore parce que l'INSEE
elle-même fait des variantes puisque
l'Insee ne sait pas non plus ce qui va
se passer nous avons parfois des
variantes démographiques voilà donc on a
des chapitres où on vous dit bâti on a
tel hypothèse de natalité qu'est-ce que
ça change sur les retraites donc tout ça
on peut le faire on peut faire même des
variantes qui ne seraient pas les
variantes de l'ipser si les membres le
demandent pour le moment ils ont l'air
de considérer que c'est
c'est
suffisant pour pour en tout cas prendre
parce que le corps notre problème c'est
pas de savoir quel est le futur parce
que bien évidemment n'en sait rien je
voulais dire on n'est pas Madame Irma
c'est de donner des éléments à ceux qui
ont décidé et à prendre des décisions
des éléments raisonnables et plus ou
moins raisonnés sur le futur parce que
bien évidemment ces décisions sont à
prendre en considération du futur mais
franchement
si je veux dire je ne serai plus là en
2070 mais si on me dit qu'en 2070 que ce
que j'avais prévu en 2022 n'était pas
bon je ne serai pas étonné d'accord mais
voilà il nous faut décider et pour nous
décider il faut nous projeter dans le
futur projetons-nous de manière
raisonnable et raisonnée en plus avec
des hypothèses qui sont plus ou moins
partagées avec un accord de tous les
membres du corps sur ben oui les
raisonnable de partir des hypothèses du
gouvernement oui sur la démographie on
fera pas mieux que ce que fait l'Insee
donc on va partir de l'Insee oui si on a
envie de savoir on peut faire une
variante voilà comment nous travaillons
et nous n'avons pas plus de plus
d'ambition ou plus de prétention surtout
donc voilà je ne connais pas le je ne
connais pas le futur sur le sol de
migratoire
a été évoqué l'hypothèse centrale de
l'Insee ce n'est pas 20.000 c'est une
des variantes c'est la variante passe
qui peut être centrale du lycée c'est 70
000 d'accord et les dernières données
parce que c'est bien sûr le domaine où
faire des prévisions
les aventureux ça dépend de la situation
internationale et des politiques
nationales qui font l'objet de débat
soutenu
euh et bien les dernières les dernières
données font que on est un peu plus de
70 000 sur la natalité l'hypothèse
centrale de l'Insee elle est à 1,80 il
se trouve que c'est le résultat de 2022
oui le dernier résultat publique donc en
gros l'hypothèse de l'Insee c'était on
va converger vers 1,80 et on va s'y
tenir voilà je alors après c'est pas si
vous voulez discuter de ces questions là
franchement moi j'ai mon avis comme tout
le monde depuis ces sujets-là
m'intéresse c'est une politique de
natalité pour échanger le sol mais c'est
pas avec moi
discutez-le avec le conseil de l'âge et
notamment ceux qui s'occupe des
politiques de l'enfance donc eux aussi
travaillent et ainsi de suite et avec
moi discuter retraite quoi voilà
il y a une question sur l'inflation oui
non je tire l'attention parce que sur la
conjoncture ça peut avoir ça peut avoir
des effets en gros vous avez vu dans
notre modèle de projection les salaires
augmentent en valeur réelle que vous
augmentez la productivité donc les
salaires augmentent plus vite que les
pensions d'accord et effectivement c'est
ce qui s'est passé dans les années
dans les années dans les années passées
d'accord et puis sur le long terme les
salaires ont augmenté plus vite que
l'inflation là dans la période de très
forte inflation 2022-2023
il est clair que
ce qui est habituel peut être inversé si
l'inflation prend du temps à se
répercuter dans les salaires et si
l'inflation est répercutée très vite
dans les pensions et donc on a vu par
exemple avec l'anticipation de la
revalorisation des pensions c'est un que
ça a été la volonté du gouvernement de
ne pas attendre au 1er janvier 2003 il
se peut que sur cette période de forte
inflation je ne sais pas quand elle va
se terminer ainsi de suite les pensions
aillent plus vite que nous manque les
salaires et que donc la diminution
projetée à long terme du niveau de vie
des retraités par rapport aux actifs et
l'ensemble de la population soit
sur contredites dans le court terme mais
attention à chaque fois distinguer le
court terme et le long terme
sur puisqu'il y a une question aussi sur
sur la baisse du niveau de vie relatif
ainsi sur relatif donc effectivement et
puis sur les divers éléments quand nous
projetons cette baisse du niveau de vie
relatif nous ne faisons pas d'hypothèse
sur d'autres éléments du niveau de vie
des retraités qui sont les revenus du
capital ainsi de suite en juin cet
élément blanc et donc quand je dis le
niveau de vie relatif des retraités va
baisser c'est lié au fait que les
pensions par rapport aux rémunérations
baisse d'accord mais attention et je
suis désolé mais dans le rapport il y a
des précautions méthodologiques aussi
sur l'interprétation de cette évolution
nous disons qu'elle est mécanique
c'est-à-dire qu'elle n'intègre pas
d'éventuelles changements de
comportement lié à la baisse même
du niveau de vie relatif des retraites
cette belle semaine du niveau de ville
des retraités si je suis économiste ce
que j'essaie d'être parfois et bien je
veux dire elle va introduire une
modification du comportement des agents
en quoi les agents peuvent-ils réagir
par rapport à quelque chose qui ne leur
plairait pas c'est à dire demain mon
niveau de vie relatif est plus faible
qu'il n'est aujourd'hui de manière de
réagir j'épargne plus pendant ma vie
active pour avoir plus de revenus du
patrimoine si je le peux ainsi de suite
et là aussi si je le peux ainsi de suite
je repousse mon âge de départ à la
retraite pour bénéficier de la Turcotte
ainsi de suite donc c'est une projection
avec ces éléments de contexte et c'est
une projection mécanique en gros
l'idée c'est mais même si on repousse
pas l'âge de la retraite par par la loi
et bien cette baisse du niveau du
relatif elle pourrait se traduire par
des modifications de comportement des
assurés et je précise bien qu'ils le
peuvent je suis je sais que certaines ne
le peuvent pas parce que ils sont au
chômage ils sont en invalidités et ainsi
de suite donc ce n'est qu'une fraction
qui ne pourrait mais c'est une des
possibilités et ça doit être prise en
compte dans la lecture de
de nos de nos résultats
donc je fais le lien avec les questions
sur le taux de surcotte oui on a montré
dans certaines analyses du corps que le
taux de surcotte n'était pas actuel
c'est à dire que on pourrait sans
dégrader sur le long terme la situation
du système de retraite faire une
surcotte supérieure à 5%, j'ai pas la le
niveau auquel il faudrait l'apporter
pour que ça soit tutoriel mais on le
calculera pour Monsieur de corsons
d'autant plus que c'est un peu plus
compliqué parce que ce taux de Turcotte
il devrait ne pas être 5% tous les ans
mais par exemple supérieur si on est un
âge de 70 ans que si on est un âge de 65
ans mais je passe parce que là on rentre
dans la technique actuelle oui nous
avons travaillé sur les écarts et la
disparité des systèmes de réversion et
je vous renvoie à la science du corps
consacré à ça et franchement
ça vaut le détour d'accord et ça vaut le
détour parce que c'est un système dont
on s'aperçoit qu'il est bourré de
contradiction je vais dire qu'une c'est
que la réversion que va toucher en des
conjoints dépend du comportement de son
ex d'accord en gros si vous êtes divorcé
avec quelqu'un pour la réversion il faut
pas que votre ex se remarie et la perte
elle est majeure donc l'idée que dans
notre système de retraite le niveau de
vie les revenus de quelqu'un puisse
dépendre de la décision que prend un
tiers avec lequel on s'est séparé
d'accord ça je pense que c'est le summum
des aberrations règle générale je porte
pas de jugement j'essaie de me tenir à
des constats là je me suis permis je me
suis permis de sortir de la réserve que
qui s'imposent je mentionne à nouveau
cette réserve pour vous dire qu'il y a
beaucoup de questions aux que je ne peux
pas répondre la question quel serait
votre proposition pour améliorer le
système ainsi de suite bien évidemment
je ne vais pas y répondre la question
sur le détournement de nos travaux ainsi
de suite je n'ai je n'ai bien évidemment
pas de d'appréciation apporter la dessus
sur la question de l'artefact 2028 20232
effectivement j'y reviens de Monsieur
Pierre Daredevil j'y reviens parce que
c'est un problème pour nous donc
d'habitude le corps avait une hypothèse
centrale de chômage à 7%. cette
hypothèse centrale de chômage ça allait
bien parce que le gouvernement avait une
hypothèse en fin de période où on était
à 8 et puis donc ça faisait une
transition assez douce et puis donc en
2021 l'hypothèse du chômage du
gouvernement en deux en 2027 c'était 8,4
d'accord en juillet 2022 on reçoit la
prévision du gouvernement et ces 5%. et
donc comme nous on fait un lissage sur
pour rejoindre la nouvelle la prévision
de long terme du corps avant ça faisait
que ça s'améliorait de cette membre et
que personne n'y voyait là il fallait
passer de 5% à 7% en 5 ans donc on avait
5 ans complètement déprimé entre 2028 et
20232 bon ça
c'est sur cette base qu'on a fait le
rapport et on a dit c'est un artefact et
puis assez vite on a corrigé en disant
bon c'était un artefact on n'avait pas
pu réagir on avait besoin de temps et
après on a tout recalculé avec une
variante à 4 et demi mais pourquoi on
n'a pas calculé dès le début avec la
variante avec 4 et demi c'est parce que
moi depuis 10 ans je subis des sarcasmes
de tous les éditorialistes quand je leur
parle de notre chômage à 4h30 parce que
il disait mais vous êtes fous on voit
bien que vous êtes des dingue au corps
donc on avait mis on avait rangé ça mais
là quand le gouvernement nous dit on est
à 5 et bien nous on ressort la variante
à 4 et demi et là je n'ai plus de
sarcasme sur mon optimisme invétéré que
j'essaie de maîtriser à vous qui les
avez en tout cas c'est pas vous qui avez
sarcasme voilà
donc après sur les conventions
eprc donc je vous ai
redis le statut de ces conventions là
aussi
il y a il y a quelques années en 2018 le
gouvernement quand il a fait une
conférence de financement avec trouver
utile les deux conventions puisque pour
donner un objectif à cette conférence de
financement il avait pris la moitié de
la convention EC et EPR pour trouver un
niveau de déficit d'accord donc cette
convention n'est pas complètement
inutile puisque elle a servi de
référence au gouvernement en 2019 pour
nous et pour l'ensemble des membres du
corps cette convention ECL un but
pédagogique pour montrer qu'une partie
du déficit est liée à
[Musique]
la question des du régime des
fonctionnaires
moi aujourd'hui j'ai préféré vous
présenter cette question là en vous
faisant vous présentant le tableau que
je vous ai présenté en disant il y a un
déficit
et il y a telle partie qui liée au
départ telle partie qu'il y ait qui est
lié aux ressources et dans les
ressources il y a l'effet fonctionnaires
il y a les faits générateur et il y
avait fait une élite et famille mais la
convention C elle permet de gommer
l'effectif fonctionnel donc c'est une
manière de de la mettre de la mettre en
exergue j'ai bien j'ai bien vu que au
Parlement d'un amendement avait été
déposé sur cette question que donc elle
posait débats j'ouvrirai le débat avec
les membres du corps
s'il me disent oui après tout notre
objectif pédagogique il est mieux avec
le tableau que je vous ai présenté
aujourd'hui et on a plus besoin de la
convention c'est je me je me ravirai à
leur position s'ils me disent je veux la
convention c'est parce que ça fait
partie aussi de notre patrimoine voilà
je laisserai la
il y avait plein d'autres questions je
suis désolé
Ah oui sur les réserves monsieur de
Coursan pardon je n'ai pas dit que
c'était un bien public au contraire j'ai
dit que on pourrait penser que c'est un
bien public mais que ce bien public il
était dans alors j'ai dit il appartenait
à certaines institutions ou à certains
régimes je ne je n'ai pas fait l'analyse
juridique pour savoir s'il fallait que
je dise que ça appartient à certaines
assurés d'accord
ou à certains régimes j'en suis à
certains régimes et donc ça veut dire
que c'est pas disponible pour comme ça
régler le problème des retraites
d'accord mais voilà simplement j'attire
l'attention sur le fait que quand par
exemple on repousse l'âge on améliore la
situation de l'ensemble des systèmes de
retraite
et notamment la situation d'art quoi
Agirc et que arco agirk et d'ores et
déjà excédentaire et elle a déjà pas mal
de réserves je vous l'ai dit et que donc
dans ce cadre là dans le bilan de la
réforme
il faudrait intégrer la réaction
plausible d'archères parce que pour le
moment ils sont en excellent et comme
nous les projettes sans même projeter la
réforme ces excédents sont permanents
d'accord donc est-ce que par quoi agir
va réagir à priori c'est comme ils ont
des réserves qui sont déjà au delà de ce
qui de ce qui leur règle de pilotage de
la décimois situé serait possible
d'accord et voilà donc voilà comment ça
c'est très lié à toute la complexité de
notre de notre système de retraite avec
sa multitude de régime
voilà bon je n'ai pas répondu à toutes
les questions je m'en excuse auprès de
vous il faudrait qu'on aille beaucoup
plus de temps et puis que je puisse
réagir avec merci monsieur Brun avec
l'autorisation de de ma collègue
ce que je propose c'est que si il y a
des députés qui ont estimé qui n'avaient
pas les réponses à leurs questions vous
le transmettiez par écrit que ça soit à
toi pour la commission des affaires
sociales ou à moi pour la commission des
finances et dans ces cas-là on vous
renverra ces questions si vous le voulez
bien de façon
je voulais dire que plus largement mais
alors sur des questions techniques pas
des appréciation le corps se tient bien
évidemment à la disposition de la
représentation nationale ça va de soi
mais de chaque député individuellement
qui auraient une question technique
précise sur telle ou tel sujet alors
dans l'équipe du corps est limitée donc
voilà mais si si on peut aider plutôt
que de faire des recherches compliquées
il y a des choses qu'on a sur étagère et
on est bien évidemment à votre service
bien merci à tous les deux d'être venu
merci
à la commission des affaires sociales et
sa président d'avoir bien voulu qu'on
coorganise je pense que c'était
intéressant vu le nombre de questions et
je pense que je pense que si des gens
réécoutent toutes les réponses qui ont
été données ils trouveront pas mal de
réponses et de ressources après chacun
les interprètes comme ils le souhaitent
pour le débat merci à vous